Dr. Peterson,
I'm really hoping you can
share your thoughts on the day.
Just shooting.
Yeah.
Well,
what I would do is recommend the
biblical lecture I did on Cain enabled,
I would say,
because I think that that's a good
summary of the state of mind that somebody
has to be in in order to do
what was done at Los Vegas.
So you have to be very,
very embittered by life in
order to do that sort of thing.
And you have to be searching for revenge,
I would say.
And it's not,
you know,
you might think,
well,
it's only revenge on other people because
you've developed a hatred for people.
But it's deeper than that.
It's not just hatred for people.
I would say it's hatred
for being itself and,
and the desire to take revenge on being
for the outrage of the tragedy and
suffering that's associated with being,
um,
and maybe the tragedy and suffering
that's been part and parcel of your own
life.
And that makes you embittered.
And then past embittered becomes
outraged and past outrage becomes well
homicidal or even genocidal.
And that's a terrible
state of mind to begin.
It's a hellish state.
Um,
I believe that the best way
to conceptualize the state
of mind that someone has
to be at in order to do something like
the Columbine shootings for example,
or what happened in Las Vegas
is that you're really an hour.
You have to speak about it
and religious languages.
You're really out for revenge against God,
for the outrage of creation.
That's what it looks like to me.
And that's a state of mind that's truly
hellish and you could get there by
broody long enough.
Now it's also possible,
I mean this guy didn't
have any previous history,
criminal history or anything
like that and he's pretty old.
So you know,
there's also all also the possibility
of some kind of neurological pathology
that that might be characteristic of him.
You know,
some degenerative neurological disease.
There was a kid years ago
at the University of Texas
in Austin who climbed up on
the tower there and shot a
number of people with a high
powered rifle and he had
a fast growing tumor on his hypothalamus
and had reported like these being
overcome with extreme feelings of rage.
And so that's another possibility.
But I would say the,
uh,
embitterment hypothesis
is the strongest one.
I would also say too,
I noticed the Steven
Pinker tweeted this today,
is that one of the ways of controlling
this sort of thing would be for the press
to agree,
not for there to be a blanket agreement,
not to publicize the name or any other
identity markers of the people who do the
shooting.
Because there's also this really,
what would you call it?
Arrogance.
It's a kind of arrogance
and pride last ditch,
arrogance and pride that
that is associated with the
fantasies that drive this
sort of behavior.
And the fantasy is like,
well,
after I do this,
everyone will sure know the who,
who the hell I was.
You know,
even though maybe I was ignored or
unhappy when I was alive after I'm get,
everybody's going to know
who I was and what idea,
you know,
so there's this underground
desire for fame,
I guess it's notoriety,
but notoriety might be
preferable to being ignored.
And so,
you know,
there's a lot of talk about gun control,
and that's understandable,
especially with regards
to automatic rifles.
Um,
although I also understand why the
people who are gun owners are afraid of,
of,
of allowing what they regarded as
one of their fundamental rights to be
infringed upon.
But it would certainly be useful if we
stopped giving people who do this sort of
thing,
not $100 million worth of free publicity
and all the notoriety they can manage.
So,
you know,
that's another way of
thinking about controlling it.
So.